you're right we are speaking
consistently and constantly
day in day out about staying at home
and we're very clear in the reasons as
to why you've all heard us say this and
others across governments cmo and many
others about the impacts on the nhs
the rules are actually very simple
and clear we are meant to stay at home
and only leave home
for a very very limited number of
reasons and that is obviously
to go to work only if you cannot work
from home
in terms of schools schools are open for
the children
pupils of key workers and then of course
you know
outdoor recreation but in a very very
restricted and limited way staying local
i've said that several times over the
last week
and obviously people that need medical
help and support and you've heard me
speak frequently as well about those
that
could suffer from violence domestic
abuse etc these are very very limited
reasons for leaving
and i think you know i i can only
actually echo the words
of dr dewalker you know we are in a
health pandemic right now
everyone has to be conscientious in
their actions and almost act and behave
as if we have covered therefore
restricting
all our social contacts so the rules are
clear
and in terms of police enforcement you
know we've spoken at length not just
today but previously martin
and all my brilliant colleagues across
policing as to the type of egregious
breaches that we will clamp down on so
the rules are clear martian do you want
to add anything to that at all
no actually i think it is really just to
make that point that
the the stay at home the reducing
contact
i think that is very clear and and
certainly
from from our perspective we will carry
on engaging with people
that's how we have done this from the
beginning we will talk to people
and we will explain but i think the
rules are are clear enough for people to
understand we are 10 months
into this process and you're right that
the regulations have shifted over that
period of time
as as the the pandemic has but i think
it's very clear what people need to do
and people need to accept the personal
responsibility to act properly
to prevent the spread of the virus